As a poet once said, "Oh, what a feeling,
when we're dancing on the ceiling," What about
spiders?
I don't want them on my ceiling, and how did
they get up there?!
Hey stickers, this is Trace, thanks for tuning
in for some DNews.
A new study in the Proceedings of the National
Academy of Sciences, found humans could never
be amazing like spiderman, we're too big!
We'd need to cover 40 percent of our whole
body with sticky pads to be able to climb
walls like a gecko or web-slinging spider,
but that got me thinking, how exactly do all
those critters do it?
How geckos cling to walls was a huge scientific
debate for millennia, until a 2002 study also
published in PNAS finally found the truth:
it's not sticky mucus, suction, or velcro
hooks, but something else entirely that keeps
them on the walls: molecular interaction.
By testing geckos on various surfaces, the
researchers realized geckos could cling to
materials that are polar.
Not polar like cold, but polar as in electromagnetism.
Van der waals forces are molecular-level interactions
first recognized in 1930.
The forces are described by quantum mechanics
and involve the electrodynamic interaction
of molecules.
Basically: all atoms have charges....some
are positively charged, while others are negative.
And atoms with opposite charges attract.
The researchers found the millions of little
hairs on some gekkan feet -- called setae
-- create a weak attraction with surfaces
whose atoms have that opposing charge.
Some gekkan setae create enough attraction
that they can can hold up to 100 times their
weight!
So in other words, it’s not about chemistry
or the amount of some miracle sticky adhesive,
it's just about the physics of those little
hairs and a particular surface.
An idea this good can't just be kept to a
small group of geckos.
Convergent evolution is when nature evolves
astonishingly similar ways to solve the same
problem in different species, and one of the
prey of geckos got this bonus too.
Spiders independently evolved setae, but theirs
take the form of protrusions on their exoskeletons.
These protrusions allow them to take advantage
of van der waals attraction too!
Thanks to their adaptations, spiders generate
three to four times their body weight in surface
force, allowing for them to quickly jump,
attack, move, or carry their own prey.
The problem is, the larger something is, the
less able they are of taking advantage of
van der waals forces.
Tree frogs, for example, need mucus to stick
to things.
Also gross.
And according to that original new PNAS study,
humans are just too big to use microscopic
hairs.
That being said, engineers are using millions
and millions of synthetic tiny hairs to create
reusable adhesive that can come unstuck again
and again!
Unfortunately, nature is still besting us,
a 2013 attempt published in Smart Materials
and Structures was only 35 percent as effective
as the strongest gecko toes.
SOMEDAY THOUGH.
Someday.
Guys, Amy and I are now on your TV box!
It's like a computer, but it's bigger and
sits in the living room.
Every weeknight at 9pm DNews now airs on Science
Channel!
Science Channel's DNews Minute airs different
stories every night to keep you even more
up-to-date on the world of science news.
If you love DNews online, come find us on-air!
Tune in every weeknight at 9, or DVR it and
BINGE.
And if you do, thanks.